let's read this question to get up a
tree a 100 meter high flagpole there it
is right there in red is observed from
two different locations
okay so observer one observer - they're
both looking up at that flagpole okay
from point A do south so that's why you
can see there's that black arrow going
down south of the flagpole the angle of
elevation at the top of the flagpole is
35 degrees pause okay angled elevation
what does that mean doesn't it it's
where you're going from the horizontally
looking up hits elevator right so
elevation just while we're on it
what's the opposite of an angle of
elevation it's when you're looking down
and angle it depression okay good
keep going it's 35 degrees from point B
the other observer due east so that's
why you can see that e going off to the
right the end of elevation is 22 degrees
fine creates the news to meet up the
distance between those two spots where
the observers are standing okay so far
with me all right let's think about this
first note okay so here's my own 3d tree
okay first I think you need to make just
a little something before we even start
doing the question is language language
I pointed out to you do oh yeah let's
think on an angle of elevation they
would follow a lot the whole question
it's a paragraph of text right so a key
extension one skill is verbal
communication in fact is some of the
extension one topic sentence to unit you
have to state an answer and ask to be
verbal you've got to explain what's
going on okay so my first point out my
first tip is really carefully read
really really carefully you would not
believe the number of students behind
heads of students every year you mess up
a question not because they can't crunch
the numbers but because they fail to
interpret the mathematical language
recap second point on
they've given us a diagram right they've
given us a diagram but you need your own
diagram this is exactly the same as when
you were doing just regular old flat 2d
geometry okay so you need to draw your
own diagram right even when you get an
exam paper and the diagrams right there
on the paper okay I think you should
call your own one and the reason why you
should draw your own one is exactly the
same as why if someone explains
something to you like oh yeah I think I
get it
but then if someone says to you can you
explain that to me you'll kind of be
like I'll get back to you because having
to articulate something yourself or draw
something yourself requires deeper
understanding in fact the process of
drawing will develop that deeper
understanding okay so let me put this
diagram back up that's right
maybe they get a rule right does anyone
need to borrow one I have something this
would be the last time I let you a rule
up because you must students who want to
do coming grab a rule up
that's alright if you're already started
during it and it's not going to do what
I'm about to say but as a general rule
of thumb the diagrams that I draw if I
want to work with them
I make them no smaller than my thumb see
that I have a pre average size Pompey
can okay if I drew a diagram any smaller
than that I'll save paper but that's
about it right it'll be too small for me
to actually gain some understanding out
of it put extra information on it if I
need to okay so I make that generally
the smallest diagram sometimes I'll even
for a bigger depending on the complexity
of what I've got okay
but this comes under the first to draw
you a diagram and make it a different a
decent size
okay now you're mostly coming towards
the end you've drawn a 3d diagram right
and you can see what they've tried to do
to explain what's going on especially
right but one of the reasons why this is
extra hard right is because even though
it's just made of triangles which you've
been doing in 5.2 right right angle
triangles because they are assembled in
three dimensions you have to develop
better spatial reasoning to understand
what's going on okay now here's my way
of unpacking you so this is um a sub
point under georeo diagram right that's
the actual diagram they've given us
we're going to draw a secondary diagram
which helps us interpret this thing so
I've got my 3d one but on top of that I
want to tease apart what's going on can
you see there are three triangles three
triangles coming in right one on the
ground two and three that are sort of up
in the air on a vertical plane okay so
those three triangles I want to draw
separately so I don't confuse them with
one another okay so let's have a go
there all right angle it right and I'm
literally going to go from left to right
okay so you can see what I've done here
right but by the way don't underestimate
this don't underestimate this you will
not get any marks for having done this
right but you will get Martin an
assessment for having got things
accurately because you drew these
diagrams right I see students they try
and save themselves 30 second that's all
it took for me to draw this right and
try and save themselves 30 seconds by
querying less diagrams and they lose
that 30 seconds back when they just
stare at a 3d diagram and they don't get
it or they make an error and they have
to come back and fix it okay so I got my
diagram I haven't started the question
yeah I'm just understanding what's going
on okay go back to that paragraph of
text what are we after what are we
trying to find very good a B is what I
want okay now another tip again for
diagrams right color color colors in
legit meaningful way to make your
diagrams that all right if you don't
have any colors to get some okay they
help you see then a complicated set of
diagrams what do you actually after here
is the distance that I want you can put
it on both diagrams you've got the 2d 1
and the 3d one so that it's absolutely
clear what you need to find all right
now we're ready okay this is what we
want but you can see obviously the
problem here is that a B is situated in
a triangle that you know absolutely
nothing about but you have no
information down there okay so these are
the triangles we know stuff about and
these are going to be our way our access
point into this triangle down here ok so
now we're going to get to work I can see
two triangles about which I know loads
of things okay I want to move from here
into here here into here what's the
common point between those look at your
3d diagram look your labels it's on it's
AC isn't it see this side is this side
you can correlate your diagrams and see
the relationship so if I can find this
that would reduce if I could find this
that'll give me this and then I've
Herrmann hose
right so right angle triangle I can just
use Pythagoras all right so let's begin
I start by saying in a particular
triangle right again do you have to
maybe triangle oh really okay but do you
want to get the question right you want
to be accurate do I know what's going on
and do you want to communicate that you
know what's going on I do so I say what
triangle I'm talking up because there's
three of them in triangle a CT
this is trig what are you going to say
what's statement you're going to write
that will get you towards what you want
any takers
yeah okay very good so pause for a
second the angle that we know is over
here and we can't find this angle but
why bother when we already have one
right relative to this we have an
opposite and an adjacent side the
opposite we know and the adjacent what
we want to know okay sir
Sarkar Toa that's why we use ten okay so
in this triangle tan of that angle is
equal to opposite and adjacent
yeah you see whoa okay now let's just
pause them so glad you said that
right our instinct is always when we
won't find something we tend to put that
up front okay yeah but it's easy to not
notice we want opposite on adjacent
opposite by adjacent this is why when I
started doing this this I would
literally first thing I write is I write
this right or if you want you can write
it like this so that it makes it really
obvious
what's over what cuz it totally changes
it right we get completely different oh
so 1035 is actually our friend rooted on
h2 subtle subtle difference 100 on AC I
won't just AC by itself so I'm going to
go multiply that across and then divide
by 1035 get here a video slide
okay there's an answer right now rich
free calculator fishery capybara and
let's actually just calculate this angle
right this side five five five okay you
got another for me what do we get
someone got it yeah okay now write this
down with me see this the calculator
display right there and I see the kids
going right now I'm writing that to
indicate this number actually it's never
ending right it's never actually going
to stop but I do want to work with
something manageable okay so I'm gonna
do two things number one before I leave
this you see while it's still on your
display right I want to use this as an
exact value now you cannot write an
exact value in the calculator but your
calculator can remember an exact time so
you've never done this before
get your calculator while that 142 point
blah blah blah is still in the display
up in the top left press shift and then
if you notice in the bottom left-hand
corner of those little little gray
buttons as a button which looks like
this right so the RCL stance will recall
we do that in a second but what we want
is the bit above that which is why you
press the shift button sto which stands
for you yes store I want to take this
down bar and I'm gonna store it in my
calculator right so I already pressed
shift press that you should notice right
on the top you display it says sto and
then did you ever notice you have all of
these pink letters above those small
gray buttons you see that I've got a b c
d e f XY m have you got those yeah okay
so pick a letter any letter I'm just
gonna pick a because I'm boring okay and
then this is what comes up on your
display okay so it's reasonably Suffolk
planetary right it's taking your answer
and it's put it into this letter so
every time you use this letter it's
going to think if
yes so in other words you're careful is
doing algebra right okay now let's just
double check that clear that off it's
all gone right your display is clear now
we can double check that now by using
the Ricoh button all right so you just
hit recall don't crush you press recall
and then go a and it should tell you
recite it back okay I've got a hundred
forty two point love that's handy we'll
hold on to them